ants have been documented to carry up to
20 times their own body weight if a
human could lift
20 times their body weight that'd be
about 4 000 pounds which would be
similar to carrying a small suv
i'm fred larabee and i'm an ant
biologist i'm john hawks
and i study humans and where we came
from today we're going to talk about
how humans lift heavy weight and why we
can't lift as much as ants
i am a computer what is human
this human and
[Music]
ants are capable of lifting very heavy
weights and they're both anatomical and
physiological traits that allow them to
do this
if a human wants to lift something heavy
and carry it
they obviously have to squat down and
lift it off the ground
for that they're using their leg muscles
and their back muscles
so if you're going to carry something
for some distance you want to have it
close to your spine
and for humans that means either having
it over your shoulder
strapping it to your back or carrying it
on your head
ants use their jaws to pick things up
and then use
muscles in their neck to lift their head
and lift the object on the ground
and then they can use their legs to
actually stabilize themselves and
carry that object wherever they want to
go the average person
if you want to carry something for a
long distance let's say several miles
then you're probably going to carry
something like a third
or less of your body weight and for a
lot of us that's going to be a lot of
work
there are people in nepal who are
working as porters who can carry
a hundred percent to almost 200 percent
of their body weight
for long distances collectively ants
can actually carry even larger objects
so as teca ants
can kill disassemble and eat prey items
that are
thousands of times their own body weight
by working together
ant mouth parts are called mandibles and
this is what they use
to grab things in their environment
whether that's digging a nest
processing food attacking prey mandibles
work on a simple hinge
and are controlled by two muscles an
opener muscle and a closer muscle
the closer muscle is incredibly large in
some leaf cutter ants
the closer muscle can take up almost
half
the volume of the head capsule and can
account for 25
of the body weight of the whole ant
humans generate bite force with
two major muscles on each side of the
skull the temporalis muscle
on the side of the skull and the
masseter muscle that comes from the
cheek
and together those make a very strong
bite force
bite force is generally measured in the
unit of force which is newtons
and ants are estimated to have bite
forces
in the range of 0.1 to 1 newton of force
which is approximately the same as the
weight of a golf ball
men can bite with a force of about 600
newtons
women are a little bit less than that an
ordinary person's
quadriceps muscles the front of their
leg can generate about as much force
so that's a pretty strong muscle an ant
invests
a lot more energy into the muscles that
control their jaw movements than humans
do
over the last two million years our jaws
and teeth have actually reduced a lot in
size
and that's probably because we started
using tools
instead of using muscles of our jaws and
the tools
enabled us to process foods externally
the consequence of this is that we've
had all kinds of
problems growing straight teeth when
people have negative encounters with
ants they often
say that they were bit by an ant but
usually this isn't the case
it's usually from a sting the majority
of ants have a stinger
just like a bee the experience of an ant
bite
would kind of depend on the kind of ant
that you're being bitten by
larger ants that have very sharp
mandibles say like a leaf cutting ant
could be a very painful bite it would be
more like
being cut with a pair of scissors than
being stung
[Music]
whereas mandibles are what ants use to
physically grasp
an object that they want to carry or
pull the main muscles that are
responsible
for lifting an object are in the neck
the neck muscles are what articulate
that object
up into the air so this is like a human
picking up a fridge with their mouth and
putting it on your back the human neck
is composed of
seven vertebrae and those seven cervical
vertebrae
are actually quite fragile looking human
necks are
relatively weak compared to the necks of
some of our close relatives
we've evolved to put our heads on the
top of our spine and to enable them to
rotate really freely without having a
lot of force necessary to hold them in
place
if we look at chimpanzees bonobos
gorillas
they're spending a lot of time
quadripedially and that means that they
have to support their head
forward all the time and that just
leads to a much stronger neck structure
and stronger muscles other insects that
are known to be good lifters
includes things like rhinoceros beetles
which have really well developed neck
muscles
rhinoceros beetles have been documented
to lift up to 30 times their body weight
they're called rhinoceros beetles
because of these elaborate horms
and they use these to engage in male
male competitions
so fights where they try to lift other
males up off the ground and throw them
out of trees
when we look at how people carry heavy
things on their heads
one reason why even relatively fragile
looking bones
can be consistent with load carrying is
that bone is very strong in
compression if you can load a bone in
such a way that you're
pushing on it like a block then that
makes it very strong
so our next the optimum way if we're
going to carry something
is to make sure that we're carrying it
with a very vertical neck
so that we're not twisting or bending or
something like that
because that's where you're in danger of
actually failure
[Music]
proportional to their body weight ants
can carry very very large
objects but that's not unique to ants
it's actually a general property of most
small animals
muscle strength and weight do not
increase in the same proportion
what that boils down to is that if you
take a small muscle
and grow it up to a very large size it
proportionally cannot
exert the same amount of force as that
small muscle
insects are small because they can't get
oxygen through their bodies
as effectively as mammals and birds can
we have a really effective circulatory
system that takes
oxygen from our lungs and courses it
through our bloodstream
to our peripheral tissues and that
actually allows us to get pretty big
we're much better than insects because
a lot of their oxygen transfer in their
bodies actually happens through hollow
tubes
and so that circulation doesn't enable
them to get as large
when we look at some earlier time
periods in earth's history like the
paleozoic
oxygen levels in the atmosphere were
actually higher than today
and insects and other arthropods
actually grew larger
so you see giant dragonflies from that
era
those giant dragonflies were able to
grow so large because the oxygen in the
atmosphere was actually higher than now
[Music]
human and insect muscles are actually
composed of the same things
and they work in the same way the only
difference is really are insect muscles
are on the inside of their skeleton
whereas humans invertebrates their
muscles are on the outside of their
bones
and that makes a big difference to the
way that their limbs have to move and
flex
the reason why we have skin instead of
exoskeletons goes
way back in our evolutionary history to
the first vertebrates
our skin enables us to interface with
our environments
in ways that are tremendously flexible
so for instance our hands
can grip onto objects and the small
sweat glands that actually make our
hands moist
tend to enhance that grip and our
fingerprints are there to
enhance the grip the exoskeleton of an
insect is basically like its outer
covering
it operates as both its skeleton just
like a human
and also like their skin and when we
look at different
types of vertebrates you see ways that
they've evolved skin
that enables them to do those things so
ducks for instance have
oily feathers and that oil is coming
from their skin
that helps to shed water really
effectively we have oil in our skin
that helps to protect us from too much
water in our environments
insect exoskeleton is basically like a
composite material
almost like fiberglass it's composed of
long chains of a sugar called chitin
embedded in a protein matrix
ants are called social insects which
means that they engage in all kinds of
collective behavior
to accomplish really complicated tasks
so here the ants have
actually cut free a disk of leaf and
they've worked together to
negotiate it into a good position and
then a single forager
has grasped that leaf lifted it up over
their head
and is now running to take it back to
their nest they also engage in other
kinds of behaviors
like building bridges with their bodies
or fire ants
when their nests get flooded with water
hold on to each other
to create a raft of ant bodies to
protect the
queen and brood and nest mates from the
rising water so things like constructing
incredibly intricate
nest architecture using really really
simple rules
no individual ant necessarily knows the
blueprint for the entire ant nest
amp brains are particularly well suited
to
help ants engage in collective behavior
particularly
by allowing them to communicate with
each other with chemical signals this
takes place
in the region of the brain that controls
the antennae ants use their antennae
similar to
humans use their nose to detect
chemicals
in their environment or from their nest
mates special receptors in the
antennae called olfactory receptors
transmit
those chemical messages to a particular
part of their brain called the olfactory
lobe
which are incredibly large in ants our
olfactory bulbs
receive olfactory sense directly from
the nose
they're quite small relative to our
overall brain size
they're tucked in underneath of our
neocortex
so olfaction is something that's evolved
a lot
one motivation for this evolution
is that we actually smell each other and
the fact that somebody may smell bad or
maybe stinky
may in part be because you don't smell
some chemicals that some people generate
and smell
more of the chemicals that other people
generate so our social interactions
are ones that involve almost a neural
simulation
of what other people in the world are
going to be like that's very complicated
compared to a mode of social
interactions that's based on olfaction
foraging ants when they find food will
lay a chemical
trail between where they found food and
their nest
that chemical trail will tell their nest
mates how to find
whatever food they're foraging on and
returning ants will continue
to lay down that chemical signal
building up that trail
to a really clear sign for the rest of
the ants on where to go to find food
each ant is following a very simple set
of algorithms and rules
on what they should do and the human
analogy is
the human brain a single neuron is not
very complicated it turns on and off
but if you put millions or billions of
these things together you get
human consciousness
if humans were to lift things like an
ant would they would have to
have really well developed jaws and so
you've got to have a huge attachment on
the top of the head to anchor those
muscles and great big muscles attached
to a really powerful jaw
then we'd also have to increase the size
of our neck muscles
and the muscles of our back to be able
to lift right and so
the back of our skull would have to
really arch out to have these
large muscle attachments fortunately our
backs are already big you know so we
wouldn't have to shift them as much
but our heads would really change a lot
[Music]
i understand an ant is not human
you